[Music]  hey drew thank you for inviting me to be  a part of your cookbook club my pick is  mediterranean cookery by claudia rodden  and the reason i love this book so much  is because i had it and started cooking  from it before i was cooking  professionally and these glossary pages  that had pictures of the ingredients  were so inspiring to me and just made me  excited about going out and shopping for  ingredients and getting into some of the  recipes there's dishes from greece and  spain and italy and egypt and i really  have such distinct memories of making  the ajo blanco  cold andalusian soup and figuring out  that  green grapes could be delicious in a  savory soup it was really a  groundbreaking time for me so pick it up  i'm sure you'll love it and find tons of  awesome recipes to make thanks again for  letting me be a part of drew's cookbook  club